Ох після війни після війни буде такий
двіж Я маю дуже хорошу пам'ять і багато
речей Я просто декому не пробачу і ті
люди які десь там в Росії гастролювали
жили працювали заробляли і вони зараз
валять таких самих як вони і я просто
від цього серпентарю душуся від сміху Я
поки що не бачу якихось серйозних
потугов вона працюванні дорожньої карти
як нам повернути людей з Євросоюзу а там
близько 8 мільйонів чоловік займатися
роздумами сидячи вдома на дивані перед
телевізором Це абсолютно не те що брати
штурмом а-а російські укріплення Зараз
який
Вибачте я не маю ілюзій щодо всього що
відбувається це буде важко і це на жаль
може бути довго сьогодні спілкуємося з
волонтером громадським діячем Сергієм
Притули
Сергій нещодавно ми повернулися з
спискою південні регіони і ви провозили
багато допомоги від вашого фонду що
привозили і як це допоможе наприклад у
Контрнаступ насправді поїздка складалася
з двох частин Перша - Це допомога
Херсонщині по лінії роботи гуманітарному
штабу нашого фонду і вже після того
Запорізький напрямок і Донбас з
допомогою по лінії
мілітарної допомоги
на Херсонщині
ситуація жахлива відверто кажучи після
того як росіяни підірвали а
каховську ГЕС і дуже прикро що якось
раптово згасла увага з боку світової
спільноти до цієї проблематики тому що
її одразу перекрили якісь там
повстанські рухи російських зеків які
йшли на Москву але потім щось з
передумали і ось це виявилось набагато
там найважливішим для великої кількості
там досліджень мейкерів якихось спільнот
які якось так відставили найбільшу
техногенну катастрофу в Європі в XXI
столітті в бік А насправді потреби
колосальні і тому там силами фонду ми
збирали кошти в якийсь спосіб допомагати
ДСНС допомагати людям то ми на контакті
з територіальними громадами на
деокупованих територіях Правобережжя
Херсонщини а
забули закопані мотопомпи 10 човнів ще
один нам подарували Ми теж його віддали
туди на на потреби дуже класну
номенклатура яку ми закупили це три
таких спеціальні машини для відкачування
мулу в таких машинах буде велика і далі
м-м потреба І власне Зараз ми там на
весь світ кричимо що люди нам треба
грейдери нам треба трактори нам треба
сміттєвози нам треба гідравлічні
інструменти для дроблення там в в
Великих якихось там бетонних плит і і
тому подібне і ну власне АА такий ще
просто позитивний момент був відвідуючи
там села які постраждали і Спілкуючись з
людьми дуже багато віри а-а в людей і
фрази що ми з тим справимося або тільки
наші перемогли
Ну ось власне
те що чекає Привіт те що чекає
найближчого
конвою
вона каже чи вказується номер заявки
куди їде кількість одиниць в
тій чи іншій посилці тобто я тут бачу у
нас гідрона є і
є дрони впала зв'язок
тактичної медицина
транспорт і оптика А чого тут найбільше
от зараз сьогодні
найбільше видається тактичної медицини і
Дронів медицина просто вона йде в
величезних кількостях що це у вас за
така валізка така як дорожня ніби що тут
зберігається
так Ну ми їх просто Ну так само як і які
ось цей Це трошки більша валізка
вони залізні бувають
ці трьохсоті матриці вони просто такі
величезні матері
зараз найбільше просять три те тобто з
тепловізійною камерою для того щоб можна
було працювати і вночі Але звичайно
найходовішим є стандартний Марк третій
Ну от зараз до речі з'явився ще один
цікавий аутел четвертий з тепловізійною
камерою але там дуже кусається ціна там
щось понад 6 тисяч доларів здається за
одиницю
Спілкуючись з військовими напряму ви для
себе робите якісь ті чи інші висновки от
Контрнаступ Зараз який він
важкий і він дуже
складний зважаючи на те що по тих
напрямках основних де він відбувається у
росіян було достатньо часу закріпитися
створити дуже серйозні фортифікаційні
споруди зробити кілька ліній оборони
проривати які буде дуже і дуже важко і
тому знову ж таки коли я читаю там якісь
коментарі чи західних експертів якихось
чи чи тут це диваниха аналітиків яких
десь не влаштовують якісь темпи відверто
кажучи від цього трошки хижа робиться Бо
е-е займатися роздумами сидячи вдома на
дивані перед телевізором Це абсолютно не
те що брати штурмом російські укріплення
і ми зараз під час останньої поїздки
якраз мали можливість поспілкуватися з
хлопцями які безпосередньо задіяні в
штурмових діях це
дуже складна робота і дуже хочеться
побажати їм всім
максимального успіху в тому що вони
роблять і сказати що Ну я сподіваюсь для
більшості нас не важливий темп можливо
як важливо щоб зберігалися життя наших
захисників і все І що був рух вперед а
ми чим зможемо там будемо підтримувати А
з чим от на вашу думку звісно крім
недоступних На жаль поки що нам літаків
Контрнаступ міг би бути ефективнішим і
йдеться взяти
Ну так чи інакше все одно це все буде
впиратися в матеріально-технічну базу в
необхідну кількість і сучасної зброї
насамперед артилерійських систем
сучасної бронетехніки
так само важливий пункт - це
протиповітряна оборона засоби так само
це засоби радіоелектронних боротьби які
вкрай важливі зараз на полі бою і у нас
також немає навіть паритету з росіянами
які дуже щільно працюють своїми рибами а
і кваліфікація особового складу е-е
вміти Користуватися
новітніми зразками зброї мотивації Слава
Богу вистачає тут у нас проблем нема
це в принципі те що я дуже люблю
це очікування поставок тобто я дуже
люблю прийти і почати рахувати так 50
м/3 Дронів
75 3Т це дуже жирно Це просто Атас
купуємо сотню
тепловізійних прицілів на переносні
зенітно-ракетні комплекси тому що з ПЗРК
також збивають це ракети які летять і
мобільні групи просять щоб дати їм
можливість працювати по ракетах збивати
і вночі тому от так от воно і за цим
всім стоять якісь десятки мільйонів
гривень вже десятки сотні скільки вже
назбирали 4,7 млрд грн з початку
повномасштабного вторгнення тому таке
працюємо колишній командувач армії США у
Європі бенхотшес генерал бенготшес
нещодавно в інтерв'ю деве розповідав
цитую цього року Україна могла би
виграти цю війну а швидкість і ціна
залежить від США на вашу думку які дії
США і чи реальні вони могли би дійсно
зробити перемогу цьогорічної
все лежить в площині
отримання Україною
ракет
радіо судді застосування набагато
більшого ніж ми маємо зараз
умовно кажучи там для того щоб діставати
ворога на дистанцію 300 500 км має
точкова застосовуємо певні зразки БПЛА
але набагато ефективніше було звичайно
застосовувати ракетні системи і звичайно
авіація сучасного там ті самі в 16 проте
і я
не знаю чи цього було б достатньо щоб
закінчити військову компанію цього року
якщо відверто навіть от з такою
допомогою
[музика]
У нас дуже
складний ворог і його чорт забирає дуже
багато
маючи фактично певний безліміт людського
ресурсу вони будуть кидати і кидати в цю
м'ясорубку сотнями тисяч людей далі не
надто помічаючи це і не маючи жодного
якогось такого суспільного спротиву
всередині країни
сказали про зброю більш дальнього
радіусу дії деякі країни все ж таки в
Європі скептично налаштовані щодо із США
до речі в тому числі щодо надання такої
зброї аби влучати по території Росії
що ви про це думаєте Як мислити от якось
це сприйняття воно зміниться з часом і
що це нам вдасться з часом зміниться на
жаль
наші очікування І
певні алгоритми дій наших союзників вони
не завжди співпадають у швидкостях ми як
країна яка воює і обливається кров'ю
кожного дня Ми хочемо вже і зараз проте
Відвідавши
минулоріччі Берлін і Брюсселі Вашингтон
і спілкуючись там з певними людьми
які володіють ситуацію приймають рішення
і тому подібне я чітко розумію що ті
протоколи які вони прописували і
цементували десятиліттями ніхто не буде
їх порушувати виключно тому що країна
яка не є членом НАТО а дуже потребує
того чи іншого вони до всього йдуть
степ-байстеп виважують ті чи інші ризики
виважують
наскільки це вплине чи не вплине на
стосунки там глобально з Росією ніхто не
розуміє як
за кадром росіяни комунікують з США чи з
країнами Євросоюзу А чи є там якісь
погрози
що може зробити Росія по якихось своїх
агентурних сітках і так далі в цих
країнах тому
працювати далі треба в цьому напрямку
однозначно на всіх рівнях є
військово-політичне керівництво держави
яке домагається і Ну до домоглося і
домагається там великих результатів
ніхто не вірив що нам будуть давати
свого часу там леопарди танки ніхто не
вірив що нам будуть давати Хай мерси е-е
зараз ми спілкуємося про там ракети і
про авіацію Я думаю що рано чи пізно це
номенклатура з'явиться на озброєнні
української армії і так само Ну мені
здається що рано чи пізно а-а приймуть
все-таки більшість наших союзників той
факт що
ми не зможемо ефективно протистояти
російській агресії без подавлення
якихось військових об'єктів на території
Російської Федерації Минулого року в
інтерв'ю ДВ ви робили свій прогноз щодо
півдня ви тоді сказали що цілком
звільнити південні регіони вдасться ще
не скоро не скоро
про це потрібно чесно говорити людям
тому що м-м
ми не ми а
ряд спікерів по сьогоднішній день
займаються бровадою за кілька місяців
засуд звільнили Херсон і частину області
щодо інших окупованих нині території які
у вас зараз думки не в принципі не дуже
відрізняються від того що я говорив
Минулого року тобто очікування
звільнення Правобережжя Херсонщини
звичайно Воно було
і на ТО були всі підстави тому що річка
Дніпро через яку було знищено шляхи
комунікації А є серйозною перепоною як
для ворогів Так зараз і для нас тобто
повільний витискання контингенту
російських військ з окупованою
територією правого берега а воно
відбулося тому що Ну у них там ситуація
була
вкрай загрозлива і
логічно було що вони відійшли А тепер у
нас не менш складна задача а-а в який
спосіб зачепитись на лівому березі
отримати плацдарми розвивати Контрнаступ
з них якщо стоїть така задача перед
військовими чи можливо це там клин вбік
бердянському Мелітополя і вже звідти
завжди хочеться щоб все відбувалося
швидко що все відбувалося так яскраво як
е відбувалась відбувалось звільнення
Харківщини тоді коли росіяни просто
посипалися на очах але очевидно що коли
ми говоримо про зараз Південний напрямок
- Це абсолютно зовсім інша історія
ніж була на на Харківщині там вони
просто не не очікували від е-е
української армії такої кри-
креативності в атаці А зараз вони дуже
сильно підготувалися І це все буде дуже
складно
тут у нас коли діти приходять на фонд
приносять нам якісь кошти і так далі ми
коли сюди приводимо тут відбувається
магія дітям дуже подобається Бо у нас
тут Привіт У нас тут відповідно апарат
яким здійснюється лазерне гравіювання
того майна яке проходить ну яке
закуповується фондом і потім відвозиться
відправляється це там гравіювання для
того щоб було видно що людські гроші
перетворюється в майно яке проходить
через фонд і по-друге щоб запобігти
можливому перепродажу цього майна тому
що на жаль бувають різні випадки але ж
от є знаєте закиди оці всі соцмережах А
ви перевіряєте чи воно гарно
використовується а ще його не вкрали і
вас там крадіями взивають в коментарях
взагалі є якась от реакція або перевірка
та на те що
в принципі серед яких закидів в
соцмережах ніколи не бачив закидів від
військовослужбовців які отримали
допомогу від фонду тобто якщо хтось
сидить вдома і йому ще здається то нехай
перехреститься наша справа це отримати
запит від військових на передній лінії
верифікувати цей запит щоб він
відповідає дійсності по можливості
забезпечити цей запит і відвести
передати людям безпосередньо в руки
тобто
юридичний супровід звичайно потребує там
трішки бюрократії ми просимо аж один
лист Уно від військової частини для того
щоб фонд який працює в полі українського
законодавства зокрема закону про
благодійну діяльність благодійні
організації ми маємо звітність не тільки
перед нашими донорами які дають гроші
але й перед державними контролюючими
органами і тому нам потрібно певна
макулатура назвемо це так для того щоб
потім не мати клопотів за звітністю
коли не бачу резону відповідати хейтерам
якимось Ну хейтеринг а нам своє робити
Ну я чесно це
чомусь людям здається що може це якось
там впливає чи там чи на емоційну якусь
складову чи ще щось насправді це якийсь
такий шум з боку але оці чвари в
коментарях Як думаєте вони не вплинуть
на те що там люди
розчаровуються почнуть менше донатити
або Майже півтора року війни Мені
здається що давно вже всі для себе Все
зрозуміли і вирішили хто хоче там
Вибачте влаштовувати срач а той завжди
знайде поживне середовище Ну мені там
заходити в коментарі щоб долучатися до
якихось незрозумілих історій комунікацій
з
юзером який я не розумію чи жива людина
чи це елемент бутоферми ну нафіга плюс В
нас завжди там соцмережах пасеться купа
АА рушнявого гіпсу
яке має на меті там так само розколювати
українське суспільство яке має навіть і
підірвати довіру до українського
волонтерського руху
власне ось цей рушнявий куток як ми його
називаємо він ще дав можливість
накопичити певну суму коштів яка потім
знову ж таки використовується для потреб
військових частенько з'являються
збиті БПЛА е-е російські
тривалості і її експерт один з
найкрутіших проектів які менеджерить Наш
фонд я реально Так захоплююся но то за
трофеїв тому потім і повертаємо і
дивіться наприклад там ну умовно танк
т-72 коштує там країни не знаю нехай 2,5
млн доларів та А ми його відновлюємо за
мільйон 300 000 грн
і танк повертається на поле бою і
російська техніка тепер працює проти
росіян за Ну за реально невеликі гроші
нещодавно ви закрили такий досить
великий крутий збір на більш ніж 100
мільйонів гривень дістати ворога усюди і
дійсно і для допомоги в небі і на воді і
на землі Це були вантажівки і дрони і ви
зізналися що донатели в свій день
народження на цей збір особисто як часто
як багато І куди ви особисто думаєте
це звичайно фонд Сергія Притули
дуже добре розумію як тут
розпоряджаються коштами на користь
української армії
цьогоріч я не можу похвалитися в
великими сумами які я задонатив там за
півроку Мабуть це десь в районі до
200,000 грн а минулоріч наша сім'я за
донатала десь в районі 650 плюс-мінус
навколо цього тисяч гривень
часом я ще доначу
на інші волонтерські ініціативи а
на початку цього року я донатив
фан-маші Єфросініної там була така
суттєва сума теж для нас для нашої сім'ї
я донати в тому що її фон займається
реабілітацією жінок та дівчат які
постраждали від сексуального насильства
під час війни
критикувати ті чи інші дії волонтерів і
Влади під час війни це ефективно я би
по-перше розділяв ці речі е-е волонтерів
і владу тому що хоч вони є дуже
пов'язані але це Зараз трошки більше
дорога з одностороннім рухом тому що
волонтери представляють плечей держави
не завжди підставляє плече волонтерам в
Україні
середньостатистичний волонтер який
допомагає армії робить Збори на свою
картку і так далі постійно ходить під
дамо ключем можливого можливих якихось
кримінальних справ по собі це не є
нормально для воюючої країни в якій
сила-силена волонтерів хоче тільки
одного щоб держава не заважала а
допомагати собі за 9 років волонтерської
роботи Я ніколи не ставив під сумнів
щирість чи ефективність чи якісь роботи
на Ну у волонтерський царині і я
сповідую філософію того що волонтерство
- це синергійне середовище і дуже прикро
бачите що на жаль є люди які вважають що
це середовище конкурентне це дуже
шкодить відверто кажучи у всьому процесу
І всім учасникам цього процесу
А щодо влади якщо критика влади якщо
навіть вона конструктивна звісно Чи вона
може бути якщо це неугульна критика якщо
це конструктивна критика а-а
Після якої можуть бути якісь
конструктивні зміни то навіть під час
війни має право місце бути подібна
критика а-а головне ну е добираючи слова
критики
формулюючи цю критику шукаючи
інструменти якими можна критикувати
завжди пам'ятати що країна у війні і
дуже добре думати е-е як ця критика може
вплинути
глобальну на процеси як всередині країни
так і ззовні тому що можна до
критикуватися до того що ми залишимося з
Росією один на один
бо надмірна критика на деяких ділянках
може підірвати
підтримку західного світу а яку ми зараз
маємо тому я би казав якісь моменти там
розбирати окремо або після війни можливо
Ох після війни після війни буде такий
двіж
Ну чесно тобто
[музика]
що далеко ходити і я і сам зараз не пушу
якісь моменти не виставляю на там
загальні якісь е-е ну там в публічний
простір тому що я розумію що це може
дуже сильно нашкодити
державі Але я маю дуже хорошу пам'ять і
багато речей Я просто декому не пробачу
того що відбувалося під час війни тому
що
Ну просто верхи цинізму Верхи
[музика]
ідіотизму поведінки
цькування людей налаштування людей один
проти одного подібні речі це не менш
згубно аніж російська агресія треба
трошечки думати головою в дорослому віці
Що ти робиш
особливо якщо в тебе є якісь авторитет
якщо за тобою йдуть люди слухають тебе
не можна займатися такими страшними
речами як руйнація
монолітності українського суспільства
перед обличчям зовнішнього ворога ми
зараз Майте на увазі когось з політиків
чи когось з громадського сектору Я маю
на увазі певну кількість людей які
задіяні і там і там
А як ви гадаєте зараз президент
Зеленський і його оточення ефективні
конкретно В цей момент для держави
Ну я ж не знаю там про яке саме оточення
президента Зеленського
Я розумію що в нього велике оточення
зараз під час війни бо
відбулась така централізація влади Коли
все так чи інакше зводиться десь до
однієї вертикалі А
це ж все
Бачите можна ж стакан розглядати як
напівпорожні А можна розглядати як
напівповний А Чи влаштовує мене як
громадянина України
[музика]
чи влаштовують мене докладені зусилля
для формування такої величезної
антипутінської коаліції яку зараз має
Україна Так мене це влаштовує але завжди
можна ввімкнути про це не домовилися ось
цього нема
ну умовно кажучи е-е я поки що не бачу
якихось серйозних потугов на працюванні
дорожньої карти як нам повернути людей з
Євросоюзу а там близько 8 мільйонів
чоловік які виїхали через війну які
стали біженцями а вимушено покинули
країну Я розумію що чим довше триватиме
війна тим менше людей буде повертатися
тому що для того щоб вони повернулися
Країна має сказати люди вертайтеся Все
буде добре буде інфраструктура буде
робота буде високий рівень життя а-а хм
Я якось не дуже помічаю щоб такий діалог
хоча б починався
а от чи вірите ви в успіх політики
реінтеграції людей з нині окупованих
територій в тому числі окупованих з 2014
року Так і я думаю що це вдасться Це
буде дуже
складний і довготривалий процес але
по фіналу успішний
чому
тому що
якщо тут же такі глобальні там речі і
підходи мають бути має відбуватися
звичайно внутрішній діалог а між людьми
які були під окупацією людьми які під
нею не були Я ніколи не забуду як наші
волонтери приїжджали
з допомогою ну по лінії роботи
гуманітарного штабу яку вони приїжджали
на харківщину і на херсонщину після
деокупації тобто люди які прожили під
окупацією там 8-9 місяців і вони були
повністю відірвані від інформаційного
поля України їм кожного дня росіяни
казали що ми звісно всегда а-а если даже
Бандери сюда вернутся они вас всех
расстреляют потому что вы изменники вони
слухали
російське радіо і вони намагали там
інтернету і так далі І коли а заходять
збройні сили України які діляться з
людьми своїм пайком коли за ними зразу
залітають волонтери з тими бусами
забезпечуючи всім медицина гігієна в
харчі сталінки телефони гаджети щоб
дітки верталися до навчання і
і люди вони такі вони там плакали просто
тому що їх приходили і обіймали і казали
Блін як класно що вас звільнили
повернулись ми так на вас чекали якби
після 2014 року Коли на Донбасі на
Луганщині певна кількість мерів
секретарів міських рад і і інших е-е чи
душів які були залучені до
псевдореферендумів на території Донбасу
якби вони присіли всі після цього то
може би у нас так а в деякі міста на
Харківщині на Донбасі не здавалися б е-е
русским там ключі від міста виносили
деякі люди а так не покаране зло стало
причиною того що хтось буде ну по а чого
Ні а давайте так зроблю все одно ж з
тими нічого не зробили той мені нічого
не буде АА
з різних боків треба буде підходити до
ситуації але я вірю в успішність
реінтеграції в Україні зараз під час по
масштабної війни тривають внутрішні
зміни пропозиції до змін Зараз президент
Зеленський пропонує ухвалити закон про
застосування англійської мови
суспільство трошки по-різному
відреагувало на перспективи цього закону
зокрема хтось каже що постраждає
розвиток української або зникне
український дубляж з кінотеатрів от як
ви як людина культури наприклад зокрема
як громадський діяч реагуєте на
можливість ухвалення такого закону ну з
дубляжем там штанга якщо відверто або
у нас це дуже крута індустрія тобто
український дубляж Він дуже
котується на світовому ринку не тому що
там світ знає українську мову але
ну майстерність наших редакторів
режисерів і акторів дубляжу вона
цінується і наші мультики як Ну як ми
мультики озвучив і повнометражні фільми
і так далі І я особисто на велику
кількість людей які задіяні у цих
процесах звичайно для них там подібно
новина була певним шоком ударом і
викликала спротиві агресію чи потрібно в
кінотеатрах показувати фільми мовою
оригіналу так потрібно показувати фільми
мовою оригінал Я думаю що це дуже хороша
ідея Але звичайно не робити це за
рахунок е-е цілої індустрії яка працює
навіть під час війни старається платить
податки і так далі Треба трошечки
радитися з людьми виносити це на якісь
попередні обговорення а не оце пробувати
так а ну-но а не про канало добре
відкатуємося назад галіма ідея студія
студія зараз Я веду свій репетаж дуже
цікаво інтересного місця я про це в
звичайному під'їзді звичайно
багатоповерхівки у місті Луганськ де
відбувається щось таке дуже дивне і
інтересне багато років тому ви
прославилися телесерирою Файна Юкрайна
зараз ви вже громадський діяч волонтери
завершили свою акторську кар'єру але
якщо пофантазувати от дивлячись на
Україну зараз і була б ідея от зробити
новий сезон файної якою би ви її зробили
і з якими персонажами з якими я б її не
робив Ну відверто кажучи там
все Що все що я хотів сказати в
контексті своєї телевізійної кар'єри я
це вже зробив
перегорнув сторінку і пішов далі Мені
там складно уявляти е-е
якесь своє існування в сегменті
креативної індустрії в той момент коли
ну дуже багато
знайомих людей вже ніколи не повернуться
бо їх ну вбила Росія І
власне існування Російської Федерації
для мене таким екзистенційним викликом
а-а
Я багатьом людям пообіцяв заочно що я
зроблю все для того щоб
їхня жертва не була даремною і мені дуже
важливо залишатися в цій системі
координат Як ви реагуєте так чи інакше
на появу в нашому інфо просторі дійсно
ось таких прямим чином розважальних
програм таких телесатир від різних
студій того самого 95 кварталу
Ну я вважаю що
все що не шкодить має право на життя
Мені більш кумедно спостерігати
насправді не за тим що хтось виготовляє
розважальний контент а частково
телебачення так розумію до цього
повернулося
Мені дуже скучно дивитися як люди які
свого часу
позашкварювалися на
темі того що не цуралися заробляти гроші
в Росії там пастись Робити вигляд ніби
немає проблеми окупованого Криму ніби
немає тисяч загиблих на Донбасі після
14-го року як вони зараз
як це правильно сформулювати Ну типу
хочеш
відбілити репутацію
моче тих хто так само зашкварився як ти
але не здогадався почати мочити тебе і
ті люди які десь там в Росії
гастролювали жили працювали заробляли і
вони зараз валять таких самих як вони і
я просто від цього серпентарю душуся від
сміху
Я не хочу на особистих зупинятися
забагато честі от у зв'язку з нещодавним
закладом пригожина у РФ була ну дуже
велика кількість мемів в тому числі за
вашою там участі чи Слідкуйте ви от за
такими народними продуктами гумору я би
Навіть якби хотів не слідкувати то
чи в там чаті там
з друзями
великі чани Куми зібрані Там трошки
колеги Ну і вони завжди якщо якісь мем
виходить Там Притула сидить Цей день
настав купуємо
ми гімна не купуємо
фон Притули купляють такі якісь хороші
правильні ефективні речі для військових
А це який шмат лайнами на це гроші не
витрачає і я завжди пригадую як під час
ракетних обстрілів в жовтні місяці я там
десь сидячи в підземному паркінгу пішов
зловив Інтернет щоб подивитися що в
світі коїться і в Фейсбуці один знайомий
пише
Так треба дотриматися до вечора там
підуть меми стане легше а от стреси від
очікувань щодо завершення швидкого
швидкого завершення війни або завершення
в цьому році в наступному якийсь енний
період часу як їх долати Як ви їх
долаєте справа в тім що для мене не було
ніяких очікувань швидкого завершення
тому там ті стреси які в мене були вони
були не пов'язані з
розчаруванням не здійснених очікування
були деякі говорящі голови які казали
дві-три недели и-и наступательный
потенциал россиян упадёт и Люди собі
зразу от як зараз там ставили дорівнює
Контрнаступ дорівнює перемога що не є
е-е так Але це закладаються підвалами і
так само люди такі а два-три тижні
дорівнює спа- наступального потенціалу
дорівнює війна закінчиться і коли на
початку квітня вибили росіян з півночі
України всі такі Ну вот же ж воно так і
складається як хтось сказав а ми весь
цей період казали е е е е е
ми контрактуємо на 3-4-5 місяців вперед
номенклатуру всяку різну тому що її
немає великі черги великі замовлення ми
проплачуємо зараз мільйонами доларів
мільйо євро все що тільки можна щоб воно
поступово заходило заходило заходило
тобто горизонт планування вже тоді був
мінімум квартал вперед а зараз зараз
мінімум півроку
Вибачте я не маю ілюзій щодо всього що
відбувається це буде важко і це на жаль
може бути довго а Звичайно що Західна
допомога має стати каталізатором а-а
процесів але Ну я думаю що
наступного року навесні
ми будемо мати мабуть ще один
Контрнаступ тому що зараз наші
наступальні дії будуть То я так міркую
собі десь до пізньої осені коли далі вже
погодні умови не дозволять там
розгортати їх в певній мірі відбудеться
якась певна фіксація лінії фронту і
перехід У більш позиційного а-а фазу
введення бойових дій і потім знову відно
ще важче мабуть ніж зараз тому що знову
буде у них можливість готуватися
нещодавно один з небагатьох таких
дописів який не пов'язаний з фондом не
пов'язаний з якимись тяжкими новинами
або актуальними новинами фронту у вас
були новини про завершення навчання в
університеті Чому ви пішли на
магістратуру в 42 роки чому вас це
зацікавило я ступив до уку влітку 2021
року а це було викликано бажанням
заповнити певні прогалини
знань в це ранній публічного управління
звичайно добре пізнавати все на
практичному досвіді але краще підходити
з певною теоретичною базою і я обрав
муку Тому що перед цим Я кілька разів
перетинався з середовищем муку власне як
людина яка вміла провести якісь заходи і
я був ведучим благодійних вечорів Я в
принципі
я не цураюся вчитися і
самовдосконалюватися Одна справа коли ти
це робиш
Працюючи на телебаченні все одно ти
мусиш працювати над собою ти десь щось
читаєш ти там готуючись до зйомок
відпрацьовуєш якусь невербальну лексику
стоячи перед дзеркалом ти не
розслабляєшся ти мусиш працювати так
само коли там приходить тобі Хм якесь
розуміння бажання змінити царину
застосування себе в своєму житті Ти
розумієш що потрібно бути більш
озброєним знаннями а не виходити в
паблік з якимось з голими ентузіазмом Як
ви гадаєте ось ви сказали про
самовдосконалення зростання чому мабуть
всім українцям варто було б на вашу
думку ще повчитися аби після нашої
Перемоги жити ще краще ніж до війни у
нас дуже
багато часу є на ненависть
і на срач Перепрошую і на жаль дуже мало
часу у нас було завжди на
турботу повагу любов навіть тут у Києві
у 2021 році коли підпалювали будівництво
реабілітаційного центру для онкохворих
діток тут на Солом'янці і це ж робили не
якісь інопланетяни і це не Путін
посипався сюди прислав це робили сусіди
які не хотіли бачити крізь вікна своїх
будинків як вони казали этих
ракаобразных ваши лысые дети будут
портить нам нашим детям настроения як
можна з такими людьми до чогось прагнути
там світло Я не знаю як їх виправити чи
це можливо але я дуже сподіваюся що хоча
б може ну їхні діти виростуть кращими
чуйнішими а
і
те що відбувалося в Україні в лютому
2022 року Все повномасштабного
вторгнення породило мені віру в те що ми
не втрачені ж ми не
що у нас може бути все добре бо я
особисто знаю купу людей які відкривали
двері своїх осель і приймали з вулиці
людей яких вони не знають які тікали від
війни з маленькими дітьми а потім
виявилося що ми можемо абсолютно
спокійно існувати без сварок навколо
якихось дрібних речей На які ми раніше
витрачали кілоджоулі енергії невже це
так важко Ні це не важко просто не плоди
ненависть і не відповідай на
срач ще більшим витком чи більшою
ненавистю А
у нас є кого ненавидіти
себе залишилось тільки любити
Дякую вам за цю розмову Сергію